[Applause]
foreign
in York for a centuries-old tradition
the Royal mondi Service
dating back to 1210 it sees the Monarch
handing out specially minted coins to
those who have served their churches and
communities
but today King Charles also acknowledged
a darker chapter in his family's past
pledging his support for a study into
their links to slavery for the first
time
the face of regular protests
not seen by his mother the late Queen
his attempts to be a progressive King
will see the institution he represents
question now more than ever
promising to look into the Royal
Family's ties to the slave trade is a
Mata the king says he takes profoundly
seriously with research expected to end
in 2026 but the protesters here Phil
those answers need to be more urgent
well I don't think they've really been
very explicit about is I think that they
will always fudge it they've not really
acknowledged their own personal Legacy
and it's difficult people might say look
you know Towers isn't responsible for
you know George III but he takes his
position as king because of George III
so you can't remember both ways
foreign
that Colonial Legacy is why some nations
are looking to lose the king as their
head of state I think that it would make
a great deal of difference uh to make
many peop many people in the in the in
the British Commonwealth particularly in
the Caribbean uh if the royal family
acknowledged not only that they were
representative of a Nation uh in
involved in slavery but they had
personal links as as well well the month
until the coronation those complex
contentious debates around issues like
this will continue
here in York opinion was divided to say
he's not okay well he is he's all about
kids isn't it whether they like it or
not yeah they live in a country where
they're allowed to do that they're
entitled to their opinions but they're
so valuable and so angry about it it
seems unnecessary really
it's clear that as the monarchy moves
into a new era one of the main questions
for now and the future is how it deals
with the issues of the past shinki
barike Sky News